foreign
it's called the illusion of vaccine
efficacy Revisited so he's done a couple
of analyzes which he cites here at the
beginning of the piece the sent the
subtitle being how to make a placebo
look 95 effective and guarantee repeat
business right which is the degree to
which that title is actually just a
literal description without any
exaggeration of what he unearths here is
amazing he and his co-author who is
Martin Neil Martin Neal yep
so the short version is this and I do
encourage you even if you don't want to
read about it there's a beautiful little
video statement video
hold on I think so but there's an eight
minute video that he does explaining the
analysis that is Crystal Clear uh that
um recommend that you go to but you're
going to explain it you're going to
explain the conclusion yeah I'm not
going to automatically robust but would
be difficult to do just in words I think
yeah I'm not having done the work
ourselves so here's the the error in the
protocol which you and I have focused on
a number of times the error in the
protocol is that people in a study that
compares a vaccinated population and an
unvaccinated population
there is a
um a shift anybody who comes down with
covid in the two-week period following
their inoculation is treated as
unvaccinated and the what I will by
protocol by yeah oh the vaccine isn't
effective right away and so we're gonna
pick us we're going to pick a period of
time uh during which yes you have
received the shot but we call you we
classify you as unvaccinated and that is
usually two weeks although sometimes is
something right here it's three so the
problem that you and I have focused on
which I think is absolutely egregious is
that there are
um immunological reasons that you might
even expect an inoculation to make you
more vulnerable to a disease like covet
and the short version of how that might
work let's say that you had had some
exposure either to a related coronavirus
or an earlier version of covet you had
an immunological response that was based
either in antibodies that respond to the
particular molecular motifs on the
surface of the of the virus or T cells
that respond to those same motifs okay
either way you've got a finite number of
detectors floating around in your system
and if you inject your system with
something that triggers the production
of proteins on the surface of the virus
then you will preoccupy a certain
fraction of your immunological cells
that can detect it right so it could be
that if you did that and so your immune
system is now reacting to vaccine
products it may miss an actual virus
that you encountered and that virus
which wouldn't have gotten through under
ordinary circumstances could get through
in that period that's at least plausible
so to say that you are effectively
unvaccinated until you've developed your
full immunity from the vaccine
is an absurdity because in some sense
what you really want to know is did this
injection make me less likely to get
coveted if it increases your likelihood
for a couple of weeks and then decreases
it for you know a couple of months
you're looking for the net impact on my
likelihood of Contracting the disease
you're not looking for after the thing
had finally done its work if it reduced
it and going to ignore everything else
so anyway that's an absurdity but that's
not what Fenton and Neil are claiming
here what they find is that
there is a
calling mathematical sleight of hand
built in here right where if you test
not the vaccine against a placebo
right so you have vaccinated and
unvaccinated but you test a placebo
against itself right and you use the
same protocol where you take anybody Who
develops the disease within the first
two weeks after they've been injected
with the placebo you treat them as
unvaccinated and you treat people who
come down with the disease after the two
weeks as vaccinated what happens is you
create a mathematical artifact in which
the vaccine looks highly effective if
you use the two-week cut off period it
looks to be almost or it looks to be
about 83 percent effective
so that turns out to be true
irrespective of the population size that
you use and irrespective of the
infectiousness of the disease in
question it's just a simple mathematical
artifact that comes from taking people
who did come down with the disease and
forcing him into the category
unvaccinated and then comparing the
unvaccinated to the vaccinated
yes I as I was concerned like this this
is an excellent piece and it's an
excellent short video and I do recommend
that people watch it I think I'm afraid
that that was a confusing explanation
there's no placebos being taken there's
no the argument is there is no way to
tell from from what was actually done if
the vaccine is better than Placebo and
in fact what we see is uh when you run
the numbers as if it was a placebo you
get exactly the same supposed efficacy
as you do when you see when you actually
look at what the vaccine rates were and
this is due to this again this you know
maybe intentional maybe not sleight of
hand with regard to moving
um the first you know for the first two
weeks after you've been vaccinated if
you're in one of these um these trials
you are categorized if you come down
with covert in those first two weeks
you're categorized as an unvaccinated
coveted case and that actually creates
exactly this graph that um that Zach is
showing here where early on it appears
that those who have been vaccinated have
a very low rate of covet in the
beginning and it appears that those who
are unvaccinated
um for like why would that change at all
in fact right like if you've had nothing
done to you why would your rates be
changing
um especially if you assume basically a
background rate of you know two percent
or one percent or five percent
infections uh you know which are all the
the numbers that he runs through
but what you see is actually those
numbers
um those numbers approach one another
the the number of coveted cases for
unvaccinated people on the number of
coveted cases for vaccinated people
approach one another very quickly
um and if you if you take out the
mathematical sleight of hand basically
all of the uh all of the evidence of
efficacy begins to fall apart well not
only that it as fent and Fenton does uh
use the same language I was using with
respect to Placebo so I don't think it
was confusing but
um
if you
um do if you generate the impression of
efficacy with this uh either error or
more likely trick
um if you do that you generate very high
efficacy at the beginning in fact again
if we have no functional vaccine
involved at all with a two-week uh cut
off you get 83 percent plus uh efficacy
and if you use a three-week cutoff as
was apparently done by the British you
get something above 90 yeah that's 100.
so but but what happens is that efficacy
drops off because it's an artifact of
what you got in the first phase you know
while people who were supposedly in this
period where they're developing immunity
differ radically because you keep
shoving the ones who got sick into the
unvaccinated group right so what that
means is you get the impression of a
very effective vaccine that
unfortunately requires regular boosting
right which I would point out as as a
Fenton and Neil imply
that is exactly what the companies that
produce these things would ideally want
the impression that what they've got is
a very good treatment or a medication
that requires uh constant boosting all
right that's that's almost ideal from
the perspective of uh of Pharma so
anyway I thought it was very interesting
for a number of reasons one
this is like the perfect level of
thought problem for a
a decent college class on statistics for
example right how do you generate the
impression how can statistics
artificially generate the impression of
a highly effective treatment for
something when there is no Effectiveness
because in fact what you've tested is a
placebo well this would be a very good
way to train people to realize that
actually
you can't just look at an efficacy
number like this and read anything
important into it because you have to
make sure that it wasn't just a simple
artifact of how you structured the the
experiment now the question though and
this is a question that has another
dimension is okay
it's subtle enough that you and I in
talking about this very particular flaw
didn't spot it okay yeah right so no and
I mean I think looking through the
article you
it took me a few times to carefully go
through what he is doing like okay
I think I Intuit this now I think I I
get it now but I still don't like I you
know I did not offer to describe it
because I don't feel that I yet have it
exactly firmly so firmly within my grasp
but I can clearly describe it I'm not
sure that we have here yet so which is
why I'm encouraging people to watch the
video read the article
um but but you know so the fact that it
is not missed that is missed by people
even people who would criticize the
delay
um isn't surprising to me but it's also
very useful for those who would have us
believe in the efficacy of these
vaccines well but I'm I'm trying to get
to something past that
the fact it is a readily comprehensible
error it is also an error that one could
structure around if that was your intent
right you could simply start the clock
at the two-week Mark and you could throw
out anything that had happened
beforehand without shuttling anybody
right yeah and you could figure out how
effective these things were and if you
know in the case of a placebo you would
see no Effectiveness right you wouldn't
get the artifact from this initial
um you know shoving of people from One
category to the other but here's the
point
this error is
subtle at first and then glaring once
you see it what is the explanation for
this emerging two years down the road
after this vaccination campaign has uh
has been in full force what is the
explanation for this not resulting in a
massive Maya culpa a refactoring of the
claims of of efficacy for the vaccines
in other words what has been Unearthed
to you if we are to believe that they
didn't know what they were doing and
they just screwed this up because
statistics are you know easy to mess up
then the point is the natural follow-on
would be a whole lot of well who did
screw this up and how did it get through
the various kinds of review and the
regulators and all of this and the
absence of that is what tells you
something here is wildly amiss I don't
know if what I said about fentanyl
Daniel's work was clear or not but in
the interest of just uh wrapping it up
if you take people who come down with
the disease
during this period in which they might
be developing full immunity if they'd
actually been injected with something
that would do that and you shove them
into the unvaccinated care category
because they are not they have not yet
reached that end point what you are
doing is defining them as unvaccinated
right they are unvaccinated by
definition you're taking sick people
people who landed in the sick category
and most of the people in the study
never end up in the sick category you're
taking people who ended up in the sick
category at the beginning of the test
period and you are making them
unvaccinated by definition so but just
to be clear you're not doing that
because they're sick
you're doing that because it's the first
two weeks after vaccination well you're
not you're not moving people between
categories because they are sick I'm not
even sure what that distinction means
because you are the reason that they got
moved was that they became sick so you
are moving them because they're sick now
why you're motivated to do that everyone
is considered unvaccinated for the first
two weeks or three weeks depending after
vaccination
well true but you're talking about
people who you did vaccinate right and
then you are shoving them into the other
category because they became sick so
this is a semantic Nuance but the point
is it is their having gotten sick that
caused you to graft them on to the
unvaccinated category which is cheating
right so
anyway it is it is an egregious breach
of the scientific Integrity here and if
it's accidental then it should have
resulted in a whole lot of backpedaling
and searching for how such an error
could have got so far into the
literature right and the fact right and
re-analysis which then should have us
you know we should be having
Congressional hearings about these
vaccines and what effect they actually
did have both positive and negative and
the point is
we see uh no no Instinct in that
direction among the people responsible
yeah sure
um I think the point you're trying to
make or to real reveal that Norman made
is that it is
assumed I think anyone who looks at
those statistics before you see the
error assumes okay if they say two weeks
down the road is when you count as
vaccinated that that's the point at
which they start the clock to start the
clock instead they've artificially
extended the clock by an extra two weeks
for you to be able to get sick if you're
unvaccinated and shortened it by two
weeks for if you are vaccinated so it's
just a four you know if you are taking
data over eight weeks it's actually
um 12 weeks and four weeks or ten and
4 respective or is 10 and 6 respectively
and so it's just two different clocks
all right that's good yeah that's good
[Music]
foreign